so those cancellations at the airport
making a lot of people frustrated and
scrambling now they want to be
compensated for all their troubles
Victoria Saha spoke with many looking
forward to ending the year in Las Vegas
only to find out their trip won't happen
Victoria joins us live from the strip
yeah Las Vegas thrives on tourism and
what better way to end the year than to
take part in America's party but with so
many people not being able to come into
town they don't know if or when they'll
be able to get a refund
this was sort of my son's only gift for
Christmas Joey Wiseman and her family
were supposed to be enjoying their first
day in Las Vegas but instead as she's
stuck at home in St Louis not knowing
how she will get her 3 500 dollars back
the money is one thing but then the
disappointment is of not being able to
to do this is another thing Wiseman says
their Southwest flight Monday night was
on time they checked their luggage in
went through TSA then at the gate found
out it was canceled along with hundreds
of others I've been on hold multiple
hours since midnight last night they
hang up on you or they just connects
over in Pittsburgh Bill Weitzel woke up
Tuesday morning to find out his Spirit
flight to Las Vegas was canceled with no
explanation I understand it's because of
the
the storms over the weekend
but
it's not bad out right now he's also
trying to find answers as to how to get
his money back from Spirit they told me
yeah three times until finally his
persistence paid off and he got an email
saying they will offer a refund the
reality of it is they have to catch up
they have to catch up on getting people
to where they need to go with no end in
sight on when Airlines will be back to
normal travel agent Abby lagman says
keep a paper trail of every
communication you have with the Airlines
and who you spoke with at the airport
there's two Travelers that you heard
would say they are also dealing with
trying to get their money back on show
bookings as well as hotels and the
travel agent says if you are planning on
traveling within the next couple days it
might be time to start looking at plan b
or just reschedule it reporting live
near the strip Victoria Saha 8 News Now